24 year old flaherty making another
postseason start he was a winner in an
elimination game against the braves
last year there's a breaking ball and he
takes care of machado
to goldschmidt and he will step on the
bag to end the inning
very patient frame from flaherty nobody
caught more games in the national league
this season than yadier molina nobody
caught more innings
than molina did and he sends his fly
ball to center field
grisham onto the track sun can be tough
in center and right carlson's looking to
move nobody's got the bag and he steals
90 feet
from an inattentive padres defense matt
carpenter at the plate
tim hill making his first appearance for
san diego
[Applause]
the side armor gives up a ground ball to
the right side covers the bag and
that'll do it
huge opportunity for the lsu product
austin nola
right down central 94 and nola goes down
looking huge
k for flaherty the padres ready
in san diego the bases are loaded and no
score
christian punched out on a fastball off
the plate inside
jack flaherty with an inconsistent
second but he came up
with a couple of huge strikeouts and
there's still no
score through two so one out base runner
and top of the order colton wong
hill looks to second fires wide they get
the outage second
but no double play and harrison bader
says check the tape
how did tatis even catch this i mean you
have
bader sliding into him a wide throw
trying to stay on the bag he does then
the cardinals have loaded the bases here
in the third
another breaking ball and carlson swings
and misses they got the matchup they
wanted
and san diego took advantage of it
ripped to the right side smothering stop
by cronenworth
and it's a one two three frame worked by
adrian motorhome
san diego has a runner at third base for
the second time in this scoreless game
cronenworth to the right side wong from
the grass
and that'll end the padres threat they
strand
two in the fourth through four tonight
not a single run on only six hits
to tatis well throws high and edmond is
safe and the cardinals have an
opportunity here in the top of the fifth
in the top of the fifth
two two straight three calls
austin adams comes up huge this bullpen
they may indeed save the day look at
look at him look at austin here's eric
hosmer at the plate
two down scoreless game in the fifth
hosmer sends a shot to left field
it gets past carlson into the fence
tatis will score
and hosmer pulls up at second base with
an rbi
double san diego has the lead in the
fifth
cardinals hitters over four with runners
in scoring position tonight
now runners at the corners now a high
fly ball
into deep right center field on the beam
on the bead grisham with a running
one-hand grab
at the wall in right center field that
might have gone yesterday
not today it's a running patch in center
field right by the wall
by tran grisham this will be the 110th
pitch of the night for jack flaherty
alex reyes is loose in the cardinals pin
strike three called he got him with 95
and he puts him down in order
in the sixth padres have the lead off
man aboard for the first time
tonight pulled to the right side picked
up by wong and the throw goes wide of
second base
krona worth remoter to third and the
padres with a huge opportunity in front
of him in the seventh
they will intentionally walk fernando
tati's junior
to load the bases for manny machado
chop to the left side kick to third
throw home need a tag
and the ball dropped by molina
cronenworth is able to score
he missed third base oh boy
and that's why you saw if your lip
reader edmonds reaction after the play
they got
nothing the padres once again a momentum
team in danger of blowing this thing
wide open three and one here comes the
pitch
osmer takes in the dirt nice pack can't
stop by molina but that is ball four and
another run
three to nothing padres here in the
seventh as grisham crosses the plate
still nobody out here's the pitch ground
ball to the right side
wong has it he will come home for the
force they get it there molina goes down
to second they'll need a tag not in time
there was still a force play there yep
that's why i went there i thought he
beat the throw
he looks out at second and i don't know
why
de young is even going for the tag so
two down
the pitch to moreland curveball struck
him out looking one another young after
a quick mound visit by nola here's the
pitch
broken bat flare diving stop tatis
the third out of the eighth comes with a
stretch from the young
superstar and if we're lucky we'll read
that again next week
chronomer the big swing here sends it
out towards deep right center field
carlson the center field are going back
at the wall he leaps it's gonna go jake
cronin worth leaves the yard
a moon shot up over the 396 sign to the
right of straight away center field
his first career postseason home run and
it's an add-on in the bottom of the
eighth
four to nothing san diego cardinals down
to their last stop they have one
four run comeback all season that came
september 19th against pittsburgh
here two out four nothing padres take
three call
this ball game belongs to my san diego
padres
[Applause]
your padres are moving on to the 2020
nationally division series against the
los angeles dodgers in arlington texas